author Frank Bruni discusses his book on
the 43rd president ambling into history
in at the New York Times reporter
chronicles george w bush's maturation as
a candidate and then as president during
this our talk mr. Bruni also shares his
observations of the Bush family
including first lady Laura Bush first
mother Barbara Bush and daughters Jenna
and Barbara Rainey
I have looked very forward to meeting
him today because I enjoyed his book and
I hope that all of you will as well he
okay
he is a reporter as a reporter for the
New York Times he covered the campaign
of george w bush for two and a half
years he's worked in the Washington
bureau and among many accolades for his
work he received the Polk award for
metropolitan reporting and was named a
finalist for the Pulitzer Prize he is
the co-author of two books consumer
terrorism and gospel of shame now a
full-time writer for The Times Sunday
magazine he lives in Washington DC his
book one of the best quotes that I've
seen in his book when I read it I'm sure
that he might be tired of already
hearing it or sing it but it's just
totally classic and it's really well
worth taking a spoke up for he says my
first and strongest impressions were of
a man chafing against and throwing off
the formal constraints of the part he
had signed up for and in reverent
rapscallion on intermittently good
behavior Jim Carrey trying to
incorporate at least a few elements of
Jimmy Stewart sometimes he succeeded
sometimes he didn't he was asking to be
king but he still reserved the right to
play the full
so I happily present to you as the
president we'll call him
Frankie boy Pancho Panchito and Brunei
Frank Bruni I was gonna read that
paragraph but I won't now
I'm not gonna do much reading cuz I'm
way too shy for that and I don't want to
see everybody's eyes glazed I've also
got a bag in my way or so I got it so I
thought I'd just talk a little bit about
why I decided to write this book and and
and what this book is about hopefully
piqued your curiosity and then I'll just
open it to questions because I think
most people would rather just have it
back and forth and I'd certainly rather
do that it's probably appropriate since
this book is about a man who did not
decide he wanted to be President or
think a lot about it until relatively
late in his life that when I began to
cover the campaign the presidential
campaign of George W Bush in in August
of 1999 I had no intention of writing a
book no idea I would write a book didn't
you know didn't consider whether I'd
have enough material or thoughts or or
even the inclination to write a book but
when the campaign ended I did feel like
I had a lot of anecdotes a lot of
thoughts in my head many things like
that that I'd never had the opportunity
to get into print in part because when
you're on the campaign trail and I and I
try to describe this in my book
you'reyou're moving so quickly and
you're turning out stories so quickly
you barely have time to tie your
shoelaces let alone think and I thought
it would be interesting to reflect on it
all and I thought it would also be
interesting for people to read and a
little bit more detail about what George
Bush is like it also struck me after the
campaign ended that he had really gone
through a pretty a pretty interesting
evolution and it was an evolution that
occurred to me I then I think was was
best defined later on September 11th but
what what you just read from the book
the paragraph you read followed an
anecdote about one of the first times
that I that I encountered George W Bush
on the campaign trail I'd been following
him around for maybe only a few weeks
and it was September of 99 and I don't
know if you all recall the horrible
church shooting that there was in Fort
Worth Texas a bunch of people dead it
was you know the latest and that sort of
string of string of tragedies like that
involving gunfire that that went back to
Columbine and even before and on a
Sunday at texan texas christian
university there was an enormous public
memorial service with thousands of
people very somber
you know somber music being play and you
know homilies all that sort of stuff and
Bush then Governor Bush was sitting a
few rows ahead of where a few of us in
the press were sitting and at an angle
so he could see where we were if he
turned around and as these ministers
were you know talking about the tragedy
that had happened and you know life and
death and god george w bush kept turning
around to look at us and shooting us
little smiles and wiggling his eyebrows
and making funny faces just you know
another opportunity to flirt with the
press and it was it was pretty
astonishing and you thought you know if
he keeps this up you know it it may look
cute to some people but he's never gonna
get to the White House and I think what
this book is about as much as anything
else is watching him from men until
almost now obviously not now cuz books
need a little time to be typeset and all
that watching him evolved from that
moment and learn to incorporate a little
bit more Jimmy Stewart into the Jim
Carrey I think I think what what
happened over time and what especially
happened after September 11th is he
began to understand more than ever
before that Americans needed something
more from him and they wanted something
more from him as they would from any
president but especially in this moment
and then a goofy charm and a and a
Blithe Spirit and I'm gonna read you
just a paragraph from later on that sort
of a counterpoint to the paragraph that
you read before the terrorist attacks
Bush had seldom attended the message
meetings at which the administration's
communicate
strategy was considered and plotted but
soon after he participated in one at the
start of each day joining heads with
Karen use Condoleezza Rice and others to
attend to the important business not
just for him but for the country of
setting the right public tone and
expectations it was Bush from the
beginning who felt most forcefully that
Americans needed to be conditioned into
thinking about the coming war against
terrorism and patient terms and that
unequip unequivocally correct relief
informed almost every public statement
he made even the ones that were
delivered more or less spontaneously you
could not listen to him over time and
fail to suspect that he understood
regardless of how prudent or effective a
response he mustered the enormity of
what had befallen the country or that he
understood how desperately Americans
were looking to him for leadership so
the book is about George W Bush first
then versus now and what I saw what I
saw him him does they are the arc that I
that I saw him on and it's not a it's
it's a kind of informal book it's not
about policy it's not about governing
per se although I think any question of
characters about governing but it's a
book that answers in a very detailed and
hopefully not too boring form the
question that I would get asked most
often when I went to cocktail parties
with friends or when I went to family
reunions with relatives you know they
never asked me so exactly how big again
is that tax cut that George Bush is
proposing or you know or I'm a little
unclear on the differences between him
his and Al Gore's positions on the
patient's Bill of Rights those are very
important things and those were
chronicled on a lot of places but what I
wanted to do is answer the question as I
said that I got asked more than any
other which is what does he really like
and this is a detailed impressionistic
and I admit sometimes snide answer to
that question it's interesting it's it's
now getting reviewed and getting talked
about more than I actually expected
expected it would and I've I've had the
pleasure of listening to a conservatives
denounced me as a hatchet man and
liberals tagged me as Bush's love slave
and to that I would just like to say I
did not set out to write this book to
bash him I didn't set out to write this
book to bolster him I just wanted to
tell you in great detail what I saw
heard felt and thought and the
two years including the first eight
months of his of his presidency in the
white house that I went you know period
during which I spent about as much time
around him as anyone who wasn't a family
member or a friend or a formal adviser
did I think he's still an enigma to most
of us to most Americans and this book is
just an attempt to this is just one one
one I hope piece of the puzzle and an
interesting piece of that I hope and
with that I'll just I'll open it to
questions and they've asked me if I
could ask you if you have anything to
ask which if you don't we're gonna have
a really brief evening to UM to come to
one of these two microphones which I
wouldn't want to do if I were in your
shoes but do you think change towards
you just suppress those things that you
found initially um I think he's I think
he's changed but probably less than I
mean it was interesting right after
September 11th I mean literally by maybe
September 15 September 16th whatever the
next Monday would be when the news
weeklies came out I was astonished to
read these columns from from writers
who'd never had a good word to say about
him and all of a sudden he was Winston
Churchill and Teddy Roosevelt rolled
into one with it with an extra vowel on
top you know I don't think that's what
happened I think that and I also don't
think at his age one changes overnight
or even over a year so I don't know what
the right verb for it is but I think
that he learned over time how to look
more frequently to certain things within
him that were always there and how to
jettison some of the things that didn't
serve his purposes as well didn't serve
the role of leader as well and didn't
make him as effective as he needed to be
what is there you said I just thought it
was close enough you said you know the
things that are there and I was
wondering what you think is there should
I take that to me you think nothing is
there sometimes you know there's no
there there dear well I don't subscribe
I don't subscribe to the belief that
he's dumb which I I think he is a smart
guy that's one of the things that's
there he's not smart it was interesting
covering him and writing about him and
thinking about him over the last couple
of years I really began to wonder what
we mean by the word smart you know and I
think too many of us when we use it
especially when we use it in print we're
talking about some rather yeah not very
nuanced measures of intelligence like
how well someone can have so how well
someone can speak how many details they
can remember you know couple moments
after they've been fed them I think he
has an instinctive kind of intelligence
a cleverness which I frequently
frequently saw in talking to him in the
kinds of situations that that most
people don't get to see because they
only see him at a podium I mean I'll
give you I'll give you one good example
he has obviously always been been hit
with the criticism that he wouldn't be
where he was if it wasn't for his father
having been president and if he didn't
have the Bush surname and I think that's
very fair a lot of us wouldn't be where
we were without certain advantages and
that's a pretty big advantage one day
after there had been an event in Iowa at
which he'd been hooked up by remote
satellite to a publishers conference
three publishers I think got to ask him
a question he was just seeing them on a
television screen and those of us in the
press corps were we're listening in
another room and watching also on a TV
set and the publisher of the New York
Times Arthur Salt's Berger got up and
asked him some question about something
I don't remember it
as soon as we got back on the plane a
few moments later he walked down the
aisle to where I sat and he looked up
and he says do you think Arthur sults
burger worked his way to the top and
then you just smiled and walked away my
point is it's not only a good line I
don't think it's the kind of thing a
dummy comes up with on the spot so
what's there that's part of what's there
I think that he is often a very earnest
man I think he is a sentimental patriot
I remember an interview I did with him
once when he started talking and this
was a interesting moment because it was
one of the first times in a long time
when it looked like he might not win it
was in early September Al Gore had come
out of the Democratic convention with an
enormous with enormous bounce that did
not dissipate as quickly as many in the
media predicted and as quickly as Bush's
advisors had hoped it would and it just
so happened that an interview request
that myself and Allison Mitchell a
colleague of mine at the Times who also
covered the bush campaign that we have
had that pending and it came through and
he started talking about almost in a
almost honest in the way of a man who
was already thinking of a concession
speech but he'd obviously just begun to
contemplate like he might lose it hadn't
looked like that was possibility for a
long time and as he began to talk about
the process of running for president as
he began to talk about the sort of
tradition of the presidency in American
history he got very teary and then he
denied that he got teary because I think
he thought it made him look a little
soft but that's another thing that's in
him that I think he's looked to since
September 11th which is I think a very
genuine patriotism do you think you had
into bush that you didn't see reported
elsewhere I think I saw almost
everything reported somewhere at some
point in time because the this year
volume of words you know that gets
spilled out during a campaign one thing
I never saw written and one thing I
wanted to write myself but sometimes
when you're writing newspaper articles
you you have the problem in that if
you're not writing an opinion column or
you're not running for the op-ed page
unless you can get somebody else to tell
you the theory you already have there's
no
way you can write it you know which is
what we're doing a lot of the times and
a theory I have I'm just sort of picking
something at random a theory I have
about for instance the selection of Dick
Cheney as vice president that I could
never get into print because it was
something you'd never be able to get a
bush adviser to say because they
wouldn't like its implication but it
occurred to me as they as his adviser
started selling the Cheney pic and
talking about how Cheney had had to had
headed up the search committee if you
remember he was supposed to be the one
so this when he became vice president
was sort of like one of the judges at
the Miss America pageant judging here
jumping out of the well and saying I'm
gonna take the tiara I'm the prettiest
you know but if you remember is very odd
he was supposed to head up the search
committee and and the story the the the
narrative that the Bush campaign put out
when it was revealed that Cheney would
be the vice presidential candidate was
that he had no interest in the job but
as he worked longer and longer around
george w bush he just became too he came
to feel so strongly about his potential
as a leader that he found he wanted to
serve him well now that's obviously a
very self-serving story but i think
there's something else about it that's
interesting and it's a window into
something which is i think choosing dick
cheney and having dick cheney say yes
for a guy who'd spent an entire lifetime
trying to measure up to his dad and to
repeat or emulate his dad's
accomplishments i think that was the
ultimate validation because here was a
man who had been one of the most one of
the core lieutenants of his father's
administration involved in the persian
gulf war which you know which when
you're around the bushes they talk about
that like it's normandy with camels i
mean it's a big thing for them and I
think for him to be able to get to
predict change for him to be able to ask
Dick Cheney and Dick Cheney to say yes I
think one of the reasons that was so
appealing and attractive to him is
because a man who had said at an earlier
moment your father is worth my total
loyalty and fidelity and service was
saying to him you're worth the same
things
the elections and at one time Bush had
an enormous lead and actually he was
like crown by the parfum party yeah
frankly no office anyway two years
before I think we've seen that three
alpha in American politics well why
don't ask at the time Bush was an
unknown quantity had been for a short
time governor of Texas my question is in
your opinion that Bush win the election
or that Al Gore loosened I'm gonna
weasel completely out of that and say a
little bit of both I mean Al Gore
certainly had enormous advantages and in
in some senses it's absolutely shocking
even today that we're here talking about
President Bush as opposed to President
Gore you know when you look at
incumbency and and you look at what the
economy was doing and and I mean it it
is rather confounding how we could lose
I don't think we'll ever know all the
reasons I mean clearly what had happened
while Clinton was in office the whole
Monica Lewinsky scandal I do think that
shadowed Gore although it shouldn't have
but I do think I think it created even
some of those Americans who in polls
would say President Clinton's doing a
good job the country is on the right
track whatever I do think it created in
some of them an appetite for change and
I think that hurt Gore so I think it's
important for us to remember that was he
the best campaigner not by a long shot
might the Democrats still be in the
White House if they'd nominated someone
else I think it's a good possibility but
no one really knows about the making of
the book when did you start writing it
what was your relationship with your
editor I wanted it go to bed and also
you had said there were some things as a
reporter you could never get into print
well there's some things you didn't
still weren't able to get into print in
this book that you would have liked to
yeah yeah I'm just because I'm gonna
take the last part of your question
first if that's okay there's a lot I
wouldn't there's a lot it that I would
like to get into print that I couldn't
even put in this book and I think one of
the real and there a number of reporters
who were actually covered the Bush
campaign with me in the room and I think
all of us would tell you the same thing
there are a number of things that happen
where someone says those hideous words
off-the-record just beforehand and I
think once those words get said there's
no you know there's there's no honest
ethical way to then put the stuff in I
think none of none of those things
contradict anything I've ever written I
think what we all do when we get told
those things is if they're completely
antithetical to what's being said on the
record and we're in a position where if
we merely wrote what was on the record
we would be lying you know we do factor
them into our thinking but so yes there
is stuff and there's stuff that I wish I
could have put in the book that I wish I
could have put in the paper that is just
for cocktail chatter and even that's
probably being a little bit bending the
rules just a little bit other stuff when
I said there was stuff I never got into
print some of it like the Cheney thing I
was just talking about it was simply
because I have the freedom in a book to
theorize even if I'm the only one doing
it as opposed to you know going out and
getting five political strategists to
say I agree with you and then saying
okay what can you say it back to me so I
can quote it and you know so there's
some of that some of it never never got
into print just because of space you
know I mean you you write a story about
a certain side to a person's personality
in this case Bush's personality and you
have two examples and a third and a
fourth would you know would be a little
bit much in a news article in a book you
got a little more time people are
spending a little more time with it you
can you know you can get it you can give
more details that add a more leisurely
pace so that's some of us and some of it
you know stuff that was told to me off
the record at one point and I was able
you know with the kind of statute of
limitation with time going by people
were a little less antsy about about
seeing it out so you know one story in
the book that I knew for quite a long
time and had never been able to get
anyone to tell it to me on background as
opposed to off-the-record but once the
campaign was over and I said around to
writing the book someone did is a story
about that and the point of this story
is sort of about how amazingly detached
Bush could be both good ways and bad
hence the story about the night before
the South Carolina primary and if you
remember back John McCain had trounced
bush in New Hampshire
he didn't look so bad in this in the
South Carolina polls and if Bush had
lost South Carolina the next primary
right after New Hampshire he might have
had some real problems I think he
probably still win the nomination but he
would have gone at the general election
kind of hobbling as opposed to riding
high and and everything might have been
different the night before that primary
huge huge night for him as he was ending
his day and walking into his hotel room
going down the hall he saw an attractive
brunette woman going into the room of
one of his one of his aides a man named
Matthew Dowd and she had a baseball cap
pulled low over her face and it made
Bush wonder if she was trying to hide or
hide from him and so when he got to his
room he continually kept calling that
night and then when he woke up in the
morning his chief political strategist
Karl Rove because he was obsessed with
knowing if that had been Matthew dad's
wife or not not because he was gonna
disapprove or anything we just kind of
want to know what was going on with
Matthew was he getting a little
extracurricular fun or whatever and it
was just it was an astonishing thing
when I heard it cuz you think you know
most people would be absolutely consumed
they'd be like you know we you know
reading exit advanced exit research or
whatever they would be looking at you
know the latest tracking polls and he
was on the phone trying to find out what
was going on with his with his aide oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry
when the campaign ended it really the
campaign ended I had a literary agent
I'd worked with in the past she
suggested I put together a book proposal
I didn't I sent her an email instead
somebody was actually interested based
on the email and just based on coverage
and all that I wrote a little bit of it
between January and the and and April
1st 2001 but I was also covering the
White House then so it was something
just I would do in little nooks and
crannies of time at night or on the
weekend and then it took about five
weeks off or at the bulk of it in those
five weeks because I didn't have to do
new research it was you know it was it
was more dire istic than that and then
went back to the White House beaten
subsequently kind of finished it up on
weekends and nights and it was it was
done more or less by June of 2001 it was
about to go into print later in the year
September 11
happened we delayed its publication and
I wrote new stuff at the beginning new
stuff at the end and new stuff scattered
throughout when he was running for
president there's several books on why
he was running for president one was
suggested to avenge his father's defeat
one said I think Elizabeth Mitchell that
was the other bar it's got the W want
but her subtitle has Bush family dynasty
yeah revenge of revenge
yeah I understand also that he felt
obliged because of his troubles when he
was a youngster and Billy Graham and
told him he you know he had to he had a
moral duty to to take the mirror to a
higher ground because of what he'd been
through well why do you think he ran
well I don't I don't think I don't think
it was nearly as simple as revenge you
know I mean that's alright
well yes so what's the rule if you leave
the room do you get your question
answered or let's just go the next
question today as he was during the 2000
campaign that the human embryo and the
human fetus both have a right to life
and also that marriage is to be reserved
for only one man and one woman is he is
sure today of that I'm I don't think
I've ever seen a wavering on that
position in either regard and maybe are
you thinking of something that happened
that's happened recently that well then
what the position he took in August it
seems like it was a political compromise
and a moral compromise regarding the
embryo as far as I I guess I didn't see
much yeah no I know someone else to do
the killing and then Rees doing research
on that well I think if you looked at
the spectrum of options available to him
on the stem-cell decision his decision
was still a pretty conservative one I
mean it was I mean if you kind of
plotted the options he had along a grow
you know along a spectrum I don't think
it was I mean my view of that decision
is it wasn't much of a compromise and if
he was more worried about the right or
the left and making that decision he
seemed to be showing more concern for
the right so so I guess I don't see that
decision is any suggestion of a
departure from his pro-life
anti-abortion whichever way you look at
a position you think he's as composed as
ever he and Laura seem happy yeah I
think so yeah yeah I have a question
about what you talked about how in what
since he's smart and I think you've
identified three things his
steadfastness his patriotism and his
patience which have served him very well
and has served the nation I think very
well since 9/11 but it's going to become
more complex as you know and and there's
some of his statements that he makes and
I don't know whether they're just for
public consumption or whether they're
really the way his mind works that give
me a little bit of concern when he sees
this as good versus evil
for example and when he says how could
they possibly hate us that doesn't show
a particularly sophisticated ability to
hold several contradictory thoughts in
your mind at the same time which strikes
me as the kind of intelligence that
might be required going forward when
this becomes a much more variegated
nuanced and complicated affair well I
think you're right that the the part of
this campaign against terrorism what you
call it that we've been through so far
as certainly the easiest party's gonna
he's going to encounter in regard to
those public statements I know the ones
you're talking about and some of them
strike me as kind of odd to it but it's
hard to separate how much of that is
simplistic thinking in him and how much
of it is just the rhetoric he's chosen
for whatever you know combination of
political and diplomatic reasons and so
that's why I'm not sure intelligence
wise what to make of them I mean apart
from that it is it is also true and I
talk a lot about this in the book it is
also true that he's not a very
intellectually curious guy he reads a
little bit more than we've given him
credit for but his field of interest is
extremely narrow he knows a lot about
the few things that really catches fancy
baseball prime among them and doesn't
really and this is I'm gonna move to
something else but it's an analogy for
using doesn't seem to always be curious
and not for just alert enough to notice
the things that most of us see in our
peripheral vision i before the book came
out there were few articles that for
some reason picked out a couple pages in
one chapter that talked about pop
culture and this really incited a lot of
conservatives who said that I was
writing that since Bush had never
watched Sex in the City he shouldn't be
president you know if I'd be a better
president if you watched Sex in the City
right but I don't think it's a
prerequisite my point in that chapter
and it was only a few pages the book is
I went through a whole bunch of things
that it became clear as we talked to him
in the back of the campaign plane that
he had never heard of he had never heard
of the television show friends he had
never heard of Stone Phillips and I
think you know at least when I surf the
channels Dateline seems to be on three
times every night he had never heard of
Leonardo DiCaprio star of the
highest-grossing in a movie of all time
Titanic and right in the age range of
the kind of heartthrob that his
daughters might you know one of them
probably at some point you know cut his
picture out of a magazine you know and
on and on and on and my point wasn't
that those things were absolutely
crucial to lead this country my
point was that most of us are have we
just sort of taken enough information
you know we look around enough that
those are the kinds of things that we
can't help but notice you know I mean I
don't I don't I don't watch car racing
but if you pressed me to answer three
cursed me to name three people who have
who have driven in the Indy appleís 500
I probably could and they don't ask me
that cuz now if I were just named to but
but you know so that so yeah you do
sometimes wonder is does he have as much
intellectual energy as you would like
him to have what he what he would tell
you what his advisers would tell you and
it's always been hard to know whether
this is a genuine belief or just very
elegant spin is that as a chief
executive to not go into the weeds to
not get obsessed with details is a
better thing because then you can just
you know set set the big basic
principles for the course and let
everybody else execute it I'll leave it
to voters to decide whether that sounds
right or not no because she's been
standing there you know cuz she's been
staying there and she went to college
with my sister so she goes thanks Frank
I have two questions my first is about
how his cabinet thinks of him not not
whether or not they like him as a person
but whether or not they respect him and
my the second part of my question is
it's about his approval weight rating in
the wake of September 11th his approval
rating with sky high but it seems like
in the last few weeks his old image is
sort of coming back first we had the
pretzel incident and then I was reading
in the Style section today in the
Washington Post about how he was
listening I think he was at the Ford
theater and he was listening to Stevie
Wonder Stevie Wonder
I realized and realized so I was
wondering I mean it seems that at least
he has a friendly impulse right how long
you think you can maintain this high
approval rating and also what you think
of him as of his leadership over the
past year I'm not gonna answer that what
I think of his leadership over the last
year because I still write news articles
and I also think the jury I mean I think
on his presidency on him on his
management of things post 9/11 I think
the jury is out on that and I don't
believe in myself enough to think I
should bring the jury in you I've
forgotten you had one of your two other
questions I've forgotten one of them
already the approval ratings the
approval ratings those are gonna go down
and I mean his own is about his own
advisers will tell you that there's no
way they're not going to go down and
there's no way they're not gonna go down
quite a bit in in somewhat of a shadow
of what happened to his dad after the
Persian Gulf War with his dad had
happened rather quickly and it is it is
widely believed and I think it's true
it's because he didn't he didn't convey
that he was turning his attention with
the same with the same degree of concern
to the homefront and I think that the
Bush White House has tried to avoid that
mistake and it's you know unclear right
now whether or not but September 11th I
think was a lot was it was a much bigger
thing in the minds of most Americans in
the Persian Gulf War I mean it was
attack on our own soil and I think
subsequent to September 11th people
desperately wanted to believe that they
had the right leader at the helm they
desperately wanted not to be arguing and
I think he was the benefit I think
anyone who had been president and done
things mostly right after September 11th
would be enjoying phenomenal approval
ratings right now and I'm not taking
away credit for him for managing things
pretty well since then which most people
feel he has although as the gentleman
over here pointed out it just gets
tougher and more difficult and more
intricate from here but I think I think
many other people in the job would have
those approval ratings right now
hey man chattering in general yes nice
to see you good spirit school together
I've been very struck by covering social
policy seeing how he's talked about
minorities in his education programs and
welfare programs during the campaign
what was his reaction to the way race
played out in the election and do you
think is something when you say Brett
you mean just in terms of sort of when
the opening and the convention opened
and there was that sort of you know
people looked at it as a show because
there's so many prominent minorities in
the party the concluding is nephew yeah
I mean the convention was really just an
extension of what they were doing all
along I mean it was it almost became a
joke in the press corps he would go to a
bush event at a school or you know any
place and if there were if there were
four minority people there they would be
there would be two on each side of him
so that so that whatever the you know
television camera picked up or whatever
a still photo and and it was interesting
and it was it was I mean it really made
you ask a lot about how you convey thing
how you convey accurate information to
voters because campaigns when it comes
to arranging photographs when it comes
to slogans all those things I don't
think campaigns and politicians would be
as aggressive at their image
manipulation and image man and image
management if it wasn't working I mean
if obviously some voters weren't
influenced by that we take a lot of heat
in the media for not adequately
informing people or getting distracted
by things that aren't important and we
do get distracted by things that aren't
important and actually write quite a
little bit about that in the book some
of the campaign coverage that we should
not be proud of but I think Americans
really have to ask themselves to what
degree they're participating in the
superficiality of politics I mean if if
you are paying so to look so little
attention that it can be effective for a
candidate to simply put a couple of
black or Hispanic faces in the TV frame
or make sure the front page picture has
those faces and that's all you see and
you don't read read into the story and
see that you know I ork it's eally or
Bob Kemper from the Chicago Tribune is
here has told you about the posing of
that of that picture then I don't know
they you know I think it's something
when you think about I think Americans
need to this isn't exactly an answer
your question but they say in politics
to answer the question you want to
answer oblivious to well I mean I think
I think all of that was set up for him I
think
his role was he he very much wanted to
be seen and this was a phrase that his
advisors talked about all the time as a
different kind of Republican and in
terms of some of his policies that
wasn't a credible sell because some of
his policies were not different many of
his policies were not different kind of
Republican policies and so where they
sought to create the impression that he
was a different kind of Republican was
with you know what I what I call the
semiotics you know and he was very much
a part of that not in planning the
events per se but in knowing that if he
didn't get away from certain images of
Republicans you know the Newt Gingrich
you know belligerent the you know Bob
Dole brooding image if he didn't seem
like a real blast of fresh air compared
to those people he was going to be
doomed and one of the main ways they did
that was to you know showcase the fact
that he spoke Spanish and had done very
well with Hispanic voters in this state
you know we spent time in black churches
you know all of that was sending a you
know subliminal and not even subliminal
message to voters that this is not your
typical Republican this is a big hearted
big tent guy and you know the question
to ask is you know and I don't want to
answer it but the question to ask is
whether you know in governing and in
terms of the policies that had
championed those things actually
dovetailed with the image he was
projecting Morris that it is a biography
of Reagan which was noted for its
unprecedented access that he had
revealed in the course of this access an
amazing number of uncomplimentary
details perhaps more than any other
author that wrote about Reagan and yet
he concluded that Reagan was a great man
and he
and he admired him tremendously some
people thought he was seduced by him
because he was flattered that he had
such access and so on how do you come
out on that I despite the the few petty
demeaning anecdotes you tell what do you
think thank you
what do you think of him
in sung which would you make the kind of
statement that that Morris made that
despite the little trivia he is in some
ways a great man or it or whatever I
don't know I mean I haven't come to
those conclusions and I really do
genuinely believe it's too soon to come
to I mean I genuinely do believe it's
too soon to come to those conclusions
when I say he's a work in progress I
really mean that and I think for
judgments like that I really think you
need the hindsight of history it's also
you know when when you when when I get
asked questions like that you know and
frequently people ask me like to compare
him to other press you know I never
covered anyone else the way I covered
him I never spent that much time in some
ways it's very hard for me to see him as
a great individual because he's the guy
I saw walking up and down the plane
eating Cheetos you know but you know I
just think we have to wait and see it's
it's his very he hasn't actually been in
public office that long I mean one of
the amazing things about him in this
presidency one of the reasons I have the
word ambling in the title is because
this is a guy who won elective office
for the very first time in 1994 when he
started campaigning for president and
was already you know like by far the
Republican choice and beating Al Gore
and very early and pretty meaningless
opinion polls and he'd only had about
four and a half years of experience in
government how did the bush daughters
manage to remain relatively so low-key
throughout the campaign process but not
forever
and did Bush sacrifice a healthy
relationship with his daughters and its
pursuit for the presidency I don't know
that he sacrificed a healthy
relationship with his daughters it's
interesting I mean I often wonder during
the campaign he talked a lot on the
stump about how family should come first
and there's nothing more important than
your children which is something I think
we've heard every politician say and I
often wondered when a person runs for
president you know be at George Bush or
Al Gore or John McCain or anyone and
knows that their kids lives will never
be the same will never be private you
know will will constantly be dogged and
you know and have a media microscope I
often wondered is that really putting
your kids first you know but I guess it
is if you really think you're the person
for the job and you really think you're
gonna make the world a better place for
your kids
his daughters you saw very little of
them during the campaign in part because
now President Bush and first lady Laura
Bush very much did not want them to
Dover by the media very much did not
want them to to go through that what was
less often said as you saw very little
living was they had very little interest
in their dads at least initially in
their dad's presidential campaign and he
would sometimes actually with a note of
regret you know say I wouldn't mind it
if they came out once or twice but they
didn't you know they were doing their
own thing didn't really like the idea of
what he was doing didn't hated the idea
of attending college with the Secret
Service entourage following them which I
don't think any of us would like and you
know I'm just I'm just going into
conjecture here because I don't pretend
to have any kind of intimate knowledge
of the Bush family but you know I did
get the sense from people around Bush
that it probably wasn't it probably
wasn't a great it wasn't it wasn't a
great improving factor or something on
their relationship and I think it was a
little bit of a strain and I'm sure
there have been a couple times since
inauguration especially when they picked
up some of the news magazines and saw
their pictures that they really wish he
hadn't wrong
having managed a presidential campaign
in States and to others I have a running
Democratic admiration for the bush
message discipline when you're in the
working press you don't always find that
the most enduring quality book but what
was your experience with that and how
much would you attribute it to staff and
how much inevitably comes back to the
candidate to some extent well I mean I
think you know obviously the staff were
the people who practice the message
discipline but I actually think that
comes back to Bush it comes back to the
people he picks I mean the biggest one
of the biggest or the biggest criteria
that uh that that he has for the people
who serve him is is unswerving loyalty
you know and one of the reasons for that
is is he doesn't want to see press leaks
he doesn't want people straying off the
reservation it doesn't want them
hypothesizing beyond the talking points
and that even goes back to his dad's
1992 loss and the belief in the Bush
family that that the first President
Bush was ill served by many of his
advisers they were chattering too much
to the press deflecting blame elsewhere
as the numbers went down and that that
really sealed his doom the message
discipline that you have ungrudgingly
nor grudging admiration for was complete
I mean it was if you if if that if the
subject of the day was you know
educational opportunity as you know the
way to help people ascend the the the
economic ladder and you asked Karen used
what the governor had for breakfast she
would probably tell you he doesn't want
to leave any child behind
we all remember when Bush chose Cheney
it was a big surprise a lot of people
thought it great you've got all the
experience at least we have one guy who
had the experience when you got elected
president some of the jokes and some of
the things written about him
what's up gold him deeply I remember
what special cartoon where Cheney I
think is sitting in the Oval Office at
the big giant and Bush had like a little
[ __ ] right where's our Saturday Night
Live parodies were he's a little desk
doing his homework you feel you were
covering him very close how do you feel
about the thing you said a few minutes
ago that he chose Cheney to show
independence and to show that he he
could be his own man and choose somebody
who had servants fatherly validation not
independent mean I don't think it was a
choice that seemed terribly independent
I mean I think it was a choice that at
the time actually seemed kind of
unimaginative you know especially I mean
one of the things that was so odd about
it and why I think you know one has to
kind of come to some theories about it
that makes sense is you know this is a
guy who was talking about I'm a
different kind of Republic I'm a
different kind of Republican imposing
you know black and Hispanic children
beside him at rallies and then he
chooses a fellow oil man white old or
you know I mean very odd choice in many
regards them kind of going a little yeah
right oh no ya know from Wyoming changed
his voter registration how did he feel
about electoral votes in Wyoming port
instead swing state how do you feel
personally when he was being portrayed
as being you know the Cheney being the
big brain behind operation and he being
like a sideshow I can only assume he
didn't like it but I mean that started
happening as as the vice president might
say big-time once they got into the Oval
once they got into the White House yeah
well the reason I really can't answer it
well is and one of the reasons why the
majority of this book is set during his
presidential campaign is there it's a
night and day difference between your
ability to get detailed information or
any sort of observational color once a
person is elected president I mean when
when we were covering the campaign
myself and some other people in this
room
we saw him everyday I mean sometimes it
was only to see him come up come onto
the plane and take a seat but we could
at least then see what he was reading or
not reading there were innumerable
moments when he would cross our paths
and there would be exchanges and as in
the grip of message discipline as his
advisors were when you're in a campaign
there's a certain not obligation but you
can't get around talking to the press a
whole bunch once your president
especially now because he's in the early
part of his presidency and he's not you
know campaigning actively for
re-election
the drawbridge goes up and there's a you
know deep deep moat around around the
president in the White House and in
almost anything you read that pretends
to tell you exactly what people are
thinking in the White House or exactly
how the president feeling is in large
measure conjecture and I've done it
myself
that's not he didn't know about friends
and you didn't know much sex in the city
but also famously he didn't know a lot
about foreign policy do you think that's
changed a lot has he educated himself
long should we still be scared well he's
obviously educated himself some I mean
you know he you know he knows who the
leader of Pakistan is now why this just
earlier lay I was just actually over
doing an hour-long radio thing on Ollie
north show of all people and and and it
was kind of confusing because one of the
things he did when we came in from one
of the breaks was to play the the audio
tape back from Bush's pop quiz that he
failed way back and I think it was
December I'm thinking wait I mean you
know this is I thought Ollie north would
be playing like the State of the Union
speech or something like that I think he
did that because he didn't think that it
was that important that one be able to
literally nail details and names like
that it's it seems to be clear watching
him in public that he has paid more
attention to the rest of the world and
to what he needs to learn about the rest
of the world since September 11th I mean
my guess is that there are still holes
in his knowledge just because this is
not a guy who stays up all night
cramming you know this is a guy who
believes whether it's genuine or whether
it is an explanation that helps him live
the way he wants to live anyway this is
a guy who believes that if you keep your
eye on the big picture you don't need to
worry too much about all the individual
brushstrokes from Korea to land mines to
going into Baghdad where State and
Defense are going to be pulling at least
to some extent in different directions
well Condoleezza Rice be the person who
basically as the tie-breaking vote on
that I don't know it's interested state
and defense music stated so we're
talking Condoleezza Rice run Rumsfeld
and that's an interesting one because I
think : you started out with I think
Colin Powell and Condoleezza Rice or I'm
getting the is that the yeah but okay I
thought you mentioned her name I'm sorry
yeah okay
Oh between those two okay I thought all
right sorry I got confused
strategic
see now I know how mean we are to these
people now that I'm standing up here you
know I don't know I don't know I mean
she of the of the people who give him
that kind of advice I can tell you she
far and away has the closest personal
relationship to him they get along
fabulously well she was the person
throughout the whole campaign who was
and and they would object to this word
and I'm using it not and I'm just using
it because it's a handy word she was his
foreign policy tutor you know they
literally have a hill at his ranch in
Crawford that they call Balkans hill
because that was where he and
Condoleezza Rice were walking when she
educated him on the Balkans
so she searched she certainly has his
ear in a different way than any of those
other foreign policy advisors do I think
we we'd be silly to underestimate Colin
pal though because he is something that
that she and that others don't have
although maybe Donald Rumsfeld's
developing it as a result as a result of
all these daily daily press conferences
since September 11th which is he's got a
cult of celebrity that's all his own
it's one of the reasons why I've never
really believed they would want him to
be a vice president he's someone who
cast a very long shadow and he has an
access to the press and an ability to
change things in the court of public
opinion that no other cabinet secretary
does because they just don't have his
fame and and don't have and they don't
enjoy the level of regard from the
American people that Colin Powell always
has you don't see the bushes around town
as nearly as much as the Clintons except
for this thing at Ford's Theater how
much of that is miss Davies wonder night
right yeah how much of that is I do to
increase security and how much is just
their own personal system well I don't
think we saw them around town as much as
the Clintons even before September 11th
so I'm sure security now factors into it
somewhat but I don't think that's the
whole of it they are home buddies you
know they are not big they are not big
out on the town socializers I think they
came home way earlier on Inauguration
night than the Clintons had some of us
actually ran you know exactly how long
they danced at each place and you know
it was usually somewhere between
like 59 seconds and and and and I I
blink you know she likes to read he
likes to go to bed at 10:00
not a lot of time to go out on the town
that she likes to read do you think
she'll have her book fair again this
year because last year I won in Texas
sir no the one he wrote DC because I
think it was only three or four days
before September 11th that was on his
Sunday and then yeah I just don't know
I've never asked anybody whether she's
gonna still have the book fair or not I
would assume they I would assume they
would like to continue it because I mean
in that vein of normalcy and and and not
seeming to have things be thrown too off
course I can't see why they wouldn't
make every effort to do it
I was Bush's Christian fundamentalist
Christians attitudes and beliefs
influenced in both through the campaign
in into September 11th well I think you
see them reflected somewhat in his
policies I mean certainly we talked
about stem cell a little bit before he
is an opponent of abortion of legal
abortion I mean if you just go by his
own words he would like to see abortion
illegal eyes dat some point in this
country and I think the Stannis held
decision was it was the decision that
reflected someone who believes as most
Christian fundamentalists do that that
life begins at conception or I think his
religion apart from whether it's
fundamentalist revenge or whatever I
think apart from that I think it
influenced influences him greatly in the
sense that it gives him a certain core
confidence that whatever he's doing at a
given moment he's meant to be doing
there were friends of his who told me
after September 11th that he said well
you now I he said variations on and I
don't have a direct quote and I want to
be careful about that because a lot of
people see this is very scary but but he
said variations on you know this must be
God's plan for me and again that's not a
direct quote but the point being that he
thought like I wouldn't be in this
position right now
unless God thought I could be able to do
it that was the impression I was left
with from their descriptions of what he
said
so whether that is frightening to people
or whether that sounds like I know
whether that sounds you know appealing
to people it's certainly I think gives
him more steadiness than he might
otherwise have you know because it gives
him a certain amount of serenity about
whatever challenges he faces Jack you
claim to have written us mostly in about
five weeks and it seems to me you've had
he's an editor at the New York Times so
he knows
certainly you've had time to polish
every word in the in the book and I
happen to know that you write very
polished stuff on deadlines - but what
since we're among journalists I'd I
would like to know him it in the heat of
the campaign did you feel that you were
able to get it across to the editors who
you were sending your message that what
was going on in the campaign were you as
the reporter there on the scene able to
get it across to us editors who are
sitting behind a desk and haven't seen
George Bush the way you have do you find
that the newspaper process gets in the
way of delivering campaign knows or well
the editors at the Times are so
uniformly spectacular that I did I don't
think I can answer the question actually
actually the truth is I mean except for
those occasions when except for those
occasions like debate nights where
you're literally filing you know finally
your deadline is rolling as the debates
going on and you're filing Lou five
paragraphs every five minutes literally
as they're speaking and nobody has time
to think about what you're doing too
much or how well it's coming across I
mean I thought yeah I was lucky I
thought the the editors listened to me I
usually did get to do what I wanted to
do right what I wanted to write and if
there was any flaw in getting across as
nuanced or as detailed to picture as I
could it was probably a flaw on my end
just you know it was the product of
exhaustion or you know being a little
too slow or deciding that I really would
watch suspect rather watch a
spectravision movie then pour over the
story one more time yeah
oh yeah there was this person who left
did that person ever come back her
really it's not a good sign right when
someone doesn't come back yeah yeah I
missed the beginning so I don't know if
you answer this already but Gary Condit
I love your profile about him I wanted
to know your thoughts about him and
whether he's guilty not in a criminal
sense but a guilty of bad judgment in
running and other things just your
general thoughts he's out of office he's
referring a couple weeks ago Network
full-time for the New York Times Sunday
magazine he's referring to a profile a
long profile of Gary Condit that was
published there by me a couple weeks ago
he went out to Modesto and spent about 6
days there and got extraordinary access
to Gary Condit and his family I don't
have an opinion at all as to I think did
you ask me whether he's guilty or not or
well I don't have any yeah I mean I
don't know I don't know whether
criminally you know he's couple or not
and I wouldn't even want to venture a
guess but one of the things that struck
me being out there and talking to him
and talking to voters and learning a
whole lot more about his political
career was that I mean he ruled that
area politically it was called conduct
country everyone referred to his conduct
country they were immensely proud of him
as a congressman and I literally mean if
you if you walk through Modesto and you
stopped six people at random two or
three of them will have a story about
something that Gary Condit Sophos did to
help them because he was so constituent
service was so important to him and he
was so on top of that stuff and his
staff was so on top of that stuff and so
what struck me was that if Gary Condit
had earlier in the game you know come
out and admitted what he eventually
tacitly did which was that he had an
affair with Chandra Levy and had made a
full you know a really full-bodied
request to his voters to
give him for that while simultaneously
saying to them and I'm taking his words
I'm not saying he isn't a cent but
saying I did nothing criminal here on
this shocked and sorry about a
disappearance I think he would have had
a chance and what he never did if you go
back and you look at it and what he
never did in his conversations with me
was ever admit fully to that portion of
what got covered that he doesn't contest
and that clearly is true and explain it
to voters in detail you know and asked
them to look beyond it and so there's
there's it's very sad in a way because
if he is innocent completely of any
wrongdoing in Chandra levees
disappearance I don't think his
political career had to end and as
everyone knows it did yesterday in the
California Democratic well maybe it
didn't and maybe there's a second act
left for him but for now yeah I think
that we have to end it now thanks thanks
everybody for coming
Frank Bruni is a reporter in the
Washington bureau of the New York Times
ambling into history the unlikely
Odyssey of George W Bush is published by
HarperCollins to learn more visit their
website HarperCollins com